[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAI PRASAD: So very
quickly, my name is Sai.
And what I'm going
to do today to start
is I'm going to run you all
through a very small story.
I'm not going to bore you all
with a talk on disability,
accessibility,
inclusivity, and all that.
Because not many
people are affected,
except the disabled
people segment.
But I'll run you through
a journey of my life.
And probably there will
be a few key takeaways.
And that's something that
you could be interested in.
So to begin with, it
all started in 1984
when a couple in South
India fell in love.
They got married,
and then I happened.
And when it
happened, obviously I
had this additional
growth in spinal cord.
The doctors did not
know how to operate.
And things got messed up.
And there you go.
I ended up with disability.
The fun part about that is that
I never knew what being normal
was.
So effectively, for me
to know what normal is
isn't even there in my mindset.
But the aspect that I was
born with a disability
came in much later in life.
I believe that there are new
terms out here these days
calling disabled people
as physically challenged
or differently abled.
If you are calling
a disabled person
as physically
challenged, it's as
if you're calling a single
person romantically challenged.
It's actually not going to make
any difference in that person's
life whatsoever.
Some people also say
disability is a state of mind.
But imagine if I was
in college, and I'm
looking at three floors.
And I have to climb
all the three floors.
And someone says,
hey, disability
is just a state of mind.
You can still climb
the three floors.
I'm basically getting nowhere
at the end of the day.
So under these circumstances,
my life took a drastic turn.
And this is what I'm going
to run you through, you all.
So in 1984, when I was
born with this disability,
it was very challenging
for my father.
My mom and dad didn't have
much of a formal education.
So it became really
difficult for them
on how do they bring
up a child like me.
There was no terms
like inclusivity,
accessibility, back then.
And a lot of people
believed that it
was sheer bad karma
in previous life
that they got blessed
with a child like me.
But my dad did something
really interesting
at that particular
point of time.
Unable to take the
pressure that comes
with having a child
with disability,
he decided that he will
actually move out of the state.
He worked for Indian Railways.
He applied for a transfer.
And we moved to Andhra Pradesh.
This is even more
problematic because moving
from Tamil Nadu
to Andhra Pradesh
means my mom right now
has a language barrier.
And she's with this kid.
And nobody knows how my
life will turn out to be.
And it's all pretty
messed up enough.
Throughout all this, we also
belonged to a typical lower
middle class family.
So effectively, while physical
disability is one challenge,
lack of finances is a completely
different ballgame altogether.
So if I get a fever, or if
I go through something which
will involve a
medical procedure,
not only is that
emotional torture,
but it is also going to
be a financial challenge.
But across all these
challenges, what kept me
going was that I was not
even aware of my disability.
Because when you're
four or six years old,
you just don't know
that you are disabled.
You just want to go out there,
play, have fun, and all that.
But the one thing
that transformed
my life was my dad's thought
that the only way out of all
the ills that are
going to come down
to me because of my disability
was through education.
He strongly believed
that education
was going to bring me
out of the challenges
that I'm going to face.
And he tried to put
me into schools.
And when he put me into
schools, the problem
was not that I had a disability.
The problem came from the
parents of other children.
Because they started to believe
that if their kid studies along
with me, then they
would mimic my habits.
Some of them in turn
believed that some
of the disability aspects that
I have were probably contagious.
And therefore, their children
will end up suffering.
So they would politely go and
tell the principal and college
administrators that they
don't want me in the class.
The college principal
will call over my parents.
And every year, this
used to be a routine.
So over eight years, I
had changed almost seven
to nine schools.
As a result, I was never
properly adapted to one place.
But the good part of it is
I had plenty of friends.
Or, at least I
thought I knew people.
So eventually, I moved
on to 10th class.
And I promised my dad
that, you know, Dad?
Whatever happens
in class 10th, I
will definitely get state first
rank in the public entrance
examination.
The fun part about that promise
was that when the results came,
I got first, but
from the bottom.
Basically, I passed
essentially with one mark.
I couldn't-- I basically scored
60% on my overall 10th class
exam.
And when the results came
on the computer screen,
my dad was shocked.
My mom started to cry.
My sister wanted to disown me.
And I was pretty much happy
that I basically passed.
So after that, when I told my
dad that I wanted to pursue
[INAUDIBLE] and all, he
just looked at me and said,
you just passed
12th class barely.
That's enough for us.
So I moved on to
class 11, class 12.
And the interesting aspect
about those two years
was that I, for the
very first time,
saw that my parents
were disappointed in me.
Think of it.
A lot of time, for us
Indians, the motivation
comes from two reasons.
One, out of passion.
The other reason is our
parents are disappointed in us.
It's like half the
life for us goes off
in proving to them that
we are worth [INAUDIBLE]..
So effectively, my teachers
were very happy after 10th class
that this fellow
even passed the exam.
But my parents
were disappointed.
For the very first
time in life, I
felt that someone had
expectations on me.
And unlike expectations creating
pressure, I actually felt good.
Because I was not
just hopeless case.
Hopeless cases are two types.
One, you don't have
hope on yourself.
Number two, others
don't have hope on you.
So effectively, I
was very, very happy
that my parents were
actually disappointed.
Because they still
had hope on me.
But somehow, when I sat down to
study, nothing went into head.
Every day to the college, my
mom would take me up on a cycle.
In front of the
entire colony, she
would kind of put
me on the cycle
and just drive me to college.
Then, exactly at 4 o'clock,
she would be there,
then bring me up back to house.
And she did that for exactly
750 times, like two years.
And even then when I
read physics, chemistry,
nothing went into head.
And I was cricket crazy.
That was the irony
of life, right?
God kind of gives you
passion for something
but doesn't give you
the talent for the same.
And that's where we want to
plug the gap with effort.
So effectively, I
was cricket crazy.
Half the time, I used to
watch cricket matches.
And one fine day,
somewhere in 2001,
there was this particular moment
where my dad was threatening me
that, I'll literally break the
TV if you don't go and study
right now.
And I told him, Dad, I
promise you I'll study.
Let Rahul Dravid get out,
and I will study for sure.
And that was a fateful day
because Rahul Dravid not only
batted that day, but he batted
for three continuous days
in that Kolkata Test match.
And I never got to study
for those three days.
But as he kept batting
and batting and batting,
I realized one thing.
He was a frustrating guy.
He's not an extremely
talented guy.
He was not the
Sachin of their team.
But he was a guy who
would never get out.
I mean, when he gets
out, India is happy.
Just imagine that.
Like, when Dravid
gets out, people
cheer because Sachin is
going to come down next.
And if our own team is
happy that he's getting out,
imagine what the
opposition would feel.
So effectively, that
particular moment,
I realized that
maybe I might not
be able to hang
around and be talented
like Sachin and my subjects.
But I'll hang around and
study and get frustrated
with physics and chemistry and
all those subjects like Dravid
would.
So I started to study for
the first time in life.
I kind of, let's say,
rectified some of the subjects
and then kind of picked up
the logic in mathematics.
And when the eventual
results came,
I secured 942nd rank in the
state engineering entrance
exam, with state first in
the physically handicapped
category.
Now, when I secured the state
first rank in the physically
handicapped category, my mom did
marketing in the entire colony.
She was like, my
son got state first.
My son got state first.
And within about 15 minutes,
the entire colony knew.
And I started to believe that
every engineering college
seat belongs to me.
Because at the end of the
day, I had the reservation.
And I thought, OK, now my life
is almost going to be set.
So when we eventually
went to counseling,
this was the funny part.
If you all watched
this movie called
"Inception," where
Christopher Nolan comes up
with this concept called
dream within dream,
our government came up with
this concept called reservation
within reservation long back.
And I was not aware of it.
So I was state first
rank in physically
handicapped category.
But I was state first
physically handicapped with OC.
The reservation was
split back then based
on the principles of not
only physically handicapped,
but also physically handicapped
and again on the cost basis.
So effectively, the
dream was to study.
It was Osmania University,
computer science.
The system put me
into CBIT College,
at electrical
engineering department.
That change in
college introduced me
to one great person.
Because if you know
where this college is,
this is literally
on-site opportunity.
So every day, you have
to travel literally 60,
70 kilometers to even
go to the college.
And on the day I took
the seat in this college
and went back home, I met
the first villain of my life.
Now, every life has a villain.
And I finally met the
villain of my life.
The villain of the life was the
next-door auntie to my house.
The day I got back to the house,
she was there waiting for me.
And she was like, you know,
Sai, did you take the seat?
And I was like, yeah,
I took the seat.
And she was like, which college?
And I said, CBIT.
And she was like, where is it?
And I said, it's there
somewhere only in the city.
And she started to rag me.
She was like, you
know, how will you go?
Will you be able
to climb the bus?
Will all these things
work out for you?
Why are you going
off troubling people
like this and all that stuff?
In five minutes,
in this where there
was no R code, no
Facebook, no Twitter,
this auntie followed my life.
And she kind of kept
an up-to-date event of,
what are the events
that are happening?
So when she realized
that my family was
going to have a tough time
with me getting educated
in an engineering college daily,
she put a status on Facebook
in her community
saying, this family
is going to suffer for
the next four years.
Then, 15 aunties
commented on it.
30 aunties shared it.
And within no time
in our colony,
we had become the
family that was going
to have a rough ride all over.
But those four years were rough.
Somehow, I managed to graduate.
I was-- one of the
advantages of being
a disabled person is that
there is so much focus that you
can put on only few events.
Because there are only few
events which you can focus on.
So effectively, my
restriction in mobility
allowed me to become a good
reader over a period of time.
I started to focus
on my education.
My dad had insisted
that if at all I am ever
going to succeed in
life, it is going
to be through education only.
And repeatedly hearing
that statement and advice
kind of over time molded me into
a person who strongly started
to believe in my dad's view.
I read this meme
earlier today saying
that when you repeat a
lie enough number of times
and loudly enough, people
will start to believe it.
The same also holds
good with truth.
When you repeat a truth
enough number of times
and say it loudly enough,
people will start to believe it.
And that's what I started
to believe as well.
I started to believe that my
education will kind of bring me
out of all troubles.
So I worked hard,
graduated again
at the top of the
university at CBIT.
And in the moment, where
I was getting placed,
I got placed with Infosys.
And finally, when I got
placed with Infosys,
Infosys asked me to move
to Mysore for training.
Now, here was a guy who,
for almost 20, 22 years,
lived with his family.
Every activity of his life was
taken care of by his parents.
So when I suddenly
moved to Infosys,
I experienced what
freedom was like.
I was happy that Infosys was not
allowing parents into campus.
If they did, my parents would
have stayed there as well.
So finally, I got
hold of a wheelchair.
I lived there for four months.
And everything was going
great until one fine day,
I met the HR.
And there was this particular
conversation I had with him.
And he said, you know what, Sai?
The postings have come out.
And you're going to
get posted to Pune.
Now, that was a shocker
for me because I was
expecting posting in Hyderabad.
So effectively, I told him, sir,
I don't want posting to Pune.
And then he said, why?
So I said, I have
this disability.
And I can't take care of myself.
So you know what?
Why don't you give me
a posting to Hyderabad?
And then he looked at
me straight on the face.
And he said, you know what?
If Pune was Paris,
wouldn't you go?
And then I looked at him back.
And I said, but
Pune is not Paris.
So effectively, I much later
realized that that's not
how you talk to HRs.
But, you know,
when you are young,
and the blood is flowing in
you, that's how you talk.
Then, he looked back at me.
And he said, you know, in a 30
years long corporate career,
one or two years here and
there should not matter.
So go.
So I just couldn't take that.
I had this huge ego back
then, believing that I
was the top of my college.
And therefore, I have
a right to whatever
posting that I want-- silly
thoughts that go on in head.
So in an emotional moment,
in a very emotional moment,
I typed an email which
was a resignation email.
And I clicked on send.
Outlook sent it.
I had no idea back then
of the consequences of it.
The shocking part was that
the HR actually accepted it.
And there you go.
Within four months of
my getting into Infosys,
I was out of the job.
Now, the bigger challenge was,
how do I tell this to my dad?
Because here I was, just
finished the training.
How do I go and tell my
dad that, you know what?
OK.
And in that moment,
I needed ideas.
So I looked at the inspiration
of our entire country, which
is Mahatma Gandhi.
Now, Gandhi wrote a letter
to his father saying,
you know, this is
what happened in life.
And Gandhi's father forgave him.
I thought the same approach
will work for me also.
So I wrote a nice
letter, telling my dad
that stuff happened.
So stuff must happen
going forward.
So we have to do
stuff in between.
And when he read the
letter, he didn't cry.
He made the other person cry.
So effectively, there
was a big fight in house.
Dad was scolding Mom.
When Dad scolds Mom, Mom cries.
When Mom cries, sister cries.
When sister cries,
Dad gets angry more.
This is called avalanche
effect basically, no?
And this was going on
crazy back in life.
And at one emotional moment,
I finally told my dad,
you know what?
I have figured this out.
When I lived in Infosys, I could
survive there for four months
because the wheelchair
was accessible--
the very first time I used
the word accessible in life.
Literally, it took me
23 years to tell my dad
that that place was accessible.
I survived there.
I think I will go
abroad and study.
The moment I said
that, Dad laughed.
And then I said,
Dad, I am serious.
And then, he got serious.
So I said-- I laughed.
And then I said, you know what?
I was just kidding around.
But that's just an idea.
So on one other fine day,
I went to this kitchen
where my mom was cooking.
And I said, ma, do you think
going abroad and studying
would be a good idea?
And she got emotional.
And she was like, would
you leave me and go?
Can you survive and all that?
Why is life like this?
I think Shani period is running
for you and all that stuff.
So she was like, let's go
and meet an astrologer.
And I was like, where is that
coming into picture right now?
So I really had no clue
what to do back then.
So I started with a
step-by-step approach.
I told my dad that,
you know what?
I'll search for a new job.
But one condition, let
me just try the GRE exam.
Let's just have that as
a backup option and see.
So effectively, my dad agreed.
I started to take the GRE exam.
And then, once the
GRE exam got cleared,
and I scored really well
on that, I went to my dad
and said, you know what?
A lot of my friends who
went abroad are doing well.
It is not that I want to go.
It's just that I want to admit
so that I can tell people
it was my choice not to go.
Because right now, when I
tell people that I did not go,
they are thinking that, who
even gave you that first to go
and all that stuff?
So then he said, OK, apply
to about three universities.
So I applied to three
universities in all--
Stanford, Wisconsin-Madison,
Texas A&M, College Station.
All the three universities
gave the admit back then.
And I was shellshocked.
Because how the hell
did they admit me?
I thought the IQ of the school
fell down by almost 10 points
the day I got the admit.
But when I saw the admit,
I was really happy.
So I went to my dad.
And I said-- now the
ultimate talk had to happen.
So I told him, we
have come this far.
Can we make the
leap going forward?
So when I look back
at that moment,
I felt that that was
a transitional point.
Because large ideas,
when you tell people,
it'll be extremely stupid.
To give you kind of
a context to this,
this is back in the freshers
party in our college.
There were two kinds of
freshers party in our college.
One was the management freshers
and the actual freshers party.
Management freshers
is like where
they give one Sprite,
one samosa and say
how great the college is.
The actual freshers
is where the seniors
invited all the juniors.
And there were three rounds
to that freshers party.
The first round was
the introduction round.
The second round was
the proposal round.
The third round was
the dance round.
To make it into the dance
round, what we had to do
was give a very good
introduction of ourselves.
And in the proposal
round, every guy
had to propose to
a girl with a rose.
And she had to
kind of accept it.
And only if she accepts, we
make it into the dance round.
When the rules were
announced, me and my friend
were shellshocked.
Because we knew that we were the
[INAUDIBLE] boys of the class.
And if we take a rose and get
onstage and call a female up,
she will be like, did
this fellow just seriously
think that I am the one
for him and all that stuff?
So effectively, as
me and my friend
sat down and wondered,
what the hell should we do,
my friend started to laugh.
And I was like, what happened?
And then he said, idea.
And whenever a friend
says idea, do not trust.
But at that point, I was naive.
So effectively, I looked at him.
And I asked him,
what's the idea?
Then he said, you
know what, Sai?
Go and propose to the most
beautiful girl in the class.
And I was like, are you crazy?
And he was like, yeah, trust me.
Go and propose to the most
beautiful girl in the class.
And I was like, what's
the point of that?
She'll reject.
And then he said,
that's the point.
When you have to take a
risk, take a maximum risk.
When you take a risk,
take a maximum risk.
If it works out, that's it.
You can do festival.
But if it doesn't
work out, nobody even
expected it to work out.
So everybody will say
that the girl was problem.
So the idea looked good.
But I also had to take a rose
and convince the female out.
So I took a rose, went to her.
And I said, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
and all that stuff.
And it didn't work out.
But much later, when I was
sitting down with my dad,
I told him, you know what, Dad?
We are taking a risk.
But if it works, great.
It doesn't work, at least
I'll become a lecturer.
So when we are taking a risk,
let's take maximum risk.
Finally, he said,
OK, let's take this.
The moment he made the
decision to support me,
that was the point where
I also thanked him.
And I said, there
was a point in life
where he was convincing me
that I should get educated.
Here was a point
in life where I was
trying to convince
him back, saying
I need education for myself.
And then he said, OK, all these
sentimental lilacs are good.
But figure out how we are going
to take care of the finances.
But on that day when
he got convinced,
and he started to tell
relatives and other people
that we have decided
to send our son abroad,
was that a madness began.
Because people were
like, are you crazy?
How would you be able
to send your son abroad?
He cannot even climb
a bus in the city.
How do you think he's going to
live abroad and all that stuff?
My mom started to become
emotionally very weak.
So I made her sat next to
YouTube, made her watch videos,
showed her how US is
accessible and much more
friendly to people
there, and tried
to do a lot of convincing.
But it didn't work out.
That was also the point
where a lot of people
actually questioned me.
They started throwing
Sanskrit quotations,
like [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] They
started to say things like,
because your time is bad, you're
getting thoughts like this.
Some other people
were like, you know,
you had a wonderful
job with Infosys.
Why quit that and
trouble your parents?
Some people even went
to an extreme extent.
They were like, you
know, your sister
won't get married if you are
doing all this crazy stuff.
And yet, at that moment, I
was really, really focused
on the education.
And there was this
big problem on,
how do I generate the
finances to study?
So me and my crazy
friend, we started
to roam around all the NGOs.
We kind of showed
them our offer letter.
And we kind of
said, you know what?
I have this admit from
Stanford and Wisconsin.
If you can go ahead
and sponsor us,
at least for the first semester,
it would be really helpful.
We roamed around
every NGO in the city.
At the end of the day, the
only one thing that we got
was the petrol bill
for the scooty.
So effectively,
nothing worked out.
And then I was really depressed.
I was fighting at
home every day.
And then one fine
day, my friend called.
And he said, idea.
And I was like, OK,
what is your idea?
And he said, let's
approach the media.
So as if that was not enough,
we approached the media,
and enough that we couldn't even
get through the security gate.
So we stood outside the security
guard for "The Hindu" newspaper
one fine day.
We started standing outside
around like 11 o'clock
in the morning.
Roughly around 3 o'clock,
one guy came out.
And as he came
out, we said, sir,
I have an admit at this
particular university.
So would you like to write
an article about us--
about me?
And then he was like,
which university
did you get an admit in?
And then I said, I got the
admit in Wisconsin and Stanford.
Would you go ahead
and write the article?
Then, he said, everybody
gets an admit for MSDs.
Just what's the big deal?
Then, my friend had
enough presence of mind.
He said, sir, but this
guy's handicapped.
So this was at that
moment a begging moment.
So we were literally selling
our disability for an article.
And then that guy was shocked.
And he was like, are
you really disabled?
And I was like, do you want
me to walk and show right now?
And effectively, he
took the interview.
And next day morning,
even as I was waking up,
there was a huge noise
outside the house.
And inside the house,
whistles were flying.
And I was like, what
the hell just happened?
So as I woke up
and was wondering
what actually happened, I
looked at-- my dad gave me
the newspaper.
"The Hindu"
newspaper, front page,
below portion, there was
this beautiful article
called "Physically Handicapped,
but Mentally Tough"
with my photograph in it.
That was not the problem.
The problem was the article
quoted my dad's salary.
And it said, this person's
salary is this much.
And therefore, he's not
able to kind of progress.
Therefore, if any kindhearted
soul is there, please sponsor.
That was also not the problem.
The problem was old villain
read this newspaper.
And effectively, she asked my
mother early in the morning,
is your husband's
salary this much only?
And this was an evil hurt.
So effectively, there was this
huge fight going on in house.
And effectively, all over
again avalanche effect
because my dad was like, when
did you even give this article?
Do you even have an
idea what happens
if you kind of pitch to the
media and stuff like that?
The TV remote broke because
I threw it on the floor
in anger and all that stuff.
Literally, I started
to feel guilty.
At one point, I just
wanted to get the hell out
of the country.
Finally, we started an
entrepreneurial venture.
And we kind of made some money.
I generated some
money to kind of cover
for the first semester expenses,
and started to go to the US,
and started pursuing
my education abroad.
In the first year at Wisconsin--
I took up Wisconsin because
it was much less expensive.
And they offered me the
computer science course.
So effectively, when
I started my course
on the very first day,
September 19, 2007,
the day I landed in Chicago,
a fantastic event happened.
Lehman Brothers collapsed.
So the world went
into recession.
So effectively, when
I [INAUDIBLE] Shani
period together happened.
So effectively, I
just didn't know
how that will impact my life.
What happened was the dollar
value went up by four rupees.
And that means the fee
increased like crazy.
And on top of that,
I thought the US
is what we see in MTV
or anything like that.
But I chose a place
where it snows.
I thought I would choose that
place because snow is cool.
Then, I realized
first snow is cold.
Second problem was I thought
when there is a lot of snow,
everybody faces
difficulty to move around.
I, by default, face
So it would kind
of get nullified.
Much later, I realized that
everybody has a way around it.
I don't.
Because when I use
my manual wheelchair,
on the snow-filled
area, it's going
to become literally crazy.
So on one fine day, I
got caught up in snow.
I collapsed because
of hypothermia.
And then when I woke
up, it was literally
two days later in a hospital,
along with a $15,000 bill.
And I was probably at the
lowest point in my life.
Looking back, I don't know what
kind of kept me going then.
I would just say that at that
particular point of time,
I was sick and tired of life.
There was-- there is
always a point in life
where, no matter how hard you
try, everything falls apart.
At that moment, some
people break forever.
Some people become numb.
They become like Joker.
They'll be like, you know, I
want to do something chaotic.
And I just decided to
continue my education
at that particular point.
Over a period of time,
scholarship opportunities
opened up.
I cracked through
the scholarship
and somehow graduated
again top of the class
in Wisconsin-Madison.
Now, here was the
interesting aspect.
When I went through
all this struggle,
and I could graduate
top of the class,
I wanted to make a fantastic
video showing people
that any person can
overcome the odds.
And they need not
struggle so much.
And so much of perception
hurts should not have happened.
So I made this
fantastic video in which
I showed what are the
facilities available for people
with disabilities in the US,
how the education system there
is different from the
education system here.
I showed how accessibility is
important and not reservation.
Because in our
country, reservation
is provided for people
with disabilities.
Reservation for people with
disabilities is like telling,
you know what?
We give you 3%
reservation, which
means that if
there is a college,
and the college has stairs,
and you are facing a challenge
to climb those
stairs, well, climb
the stairs no matter what.
But if you get
low marks, I still
kind of give you the admit.
It just does not make sense
that you solve the disability
problem with a reservation.
You need to solve the disability
problem with accessibility.
So I made a fantastic
video explaining this
and put it on YouTube.
Two people watched it--
me, my friend.
OK, my friend gave up halfway.
So effectively, I was like,
what the hell just happened?
And I tried to promote that
video as much as possible.
And nothing worked out.
So on that fateful day,
I was a little low.
And when I was going back,
and my mother's birthday
was coming up--
and when my mom's
birthday was coming up,
I'd never missed celebrating
her birthday at any time.
So this time, I wanted to
celebrate it in a very big way.
And since I was just about
to graduate, I decided--
I saw this ad for skydiving.
So when me and my
friend were there
standing next to each
other, my friend said, idea.
And I was like, OK,
what's your idea?
And he said, you know what?
Get on top of the plane.
Let's take the flight to 14,000
feet, jump out of the flight,
and then wish your
mom happy birthday
in front of the whole world.
So the idea looked good.
In an emotional moment, I paid.
On top of the flight,
when I wanted to jump,
I jumped, but because I paid.
Primarily because if I
hadn't jumped out of there,
and my dad came to know it,
he would have pushed me.
He would have called
the flight back
and said, jump all over again.
When I was in the
midair, I had forgotten
that it was my mom's birthday.
Because I had to get down.
Because my mom's birthday
would have been probably
my death day.
And I also realized that
normally when people skydive,
and they get land, they
land on their feet and walk.
Whereas with me,
the legs were tied.
Because I cannot land.
And before landing in, I had
to bend down, pull the legs
upwards, and land on my back.
And we had no idea how
this was going to work out.
But that's what you do when
you're emotional, stupid,
and younger.
And finally, when we
kind of took the risk,
came down, and landed, my
friend had enough common sense
to put an Indian
flag in my hand.
And together, both
of us screamed
that this is for
the cause of people
with disabilities in India.
That video went viral.
And people were like,
disabled guys skydive.
Disabled guys skydive.
Some people were like, you are
my inspiration, and all that.
So there was this actual
video where I talked sense.
And there was
another video, which
had no relation whatsoever
with disability--
it was just about a guy
jumping from a plane.
And when he skydived,
people were like--
they were caught.
And the attention was there.
And that's when I
actually understood
that in India, the messaging
needs to be a little different.
So that was the
first point I started
to think maybe we
shouldn't preach
to people about accessibility.
We should probably try it
from a different angle.
So I started with
analyzing the root cause
to try and find out,
why is there a stigma
associated with the
word disability?
And that took me to
religious textbooks.
The first book that I read
was this "Bhagavad Gita" book,
where I read the
word called "karma."
People said, you
experience disability
because you did bad
karma in previous life.
And imagine as a disabled
person, you're reading this.
This is Lord Krishna telling
you on your face, your last
[INAUDIBLE] tough.
This [INAUDIBLE],, you are
going to experience stuff.
That hurt.
But as I was reading
that book further,
I also started to read in
that book that he said,
life is composed of five
elements-- sky, earth, water,
fire, air.
And he then adds,
only a person who
has a straight,
vertical spinal cord
can experience all these
five elements to totality.
And I was like, OK,
this is where I got you.
Because if that is
what you want, and you
tell that only a person with
complete, straight spinal cord
can experience this,
let me prove to you
that that's not true.
So I came up with
this elaborate plan
that for sky, we
started with skydiving.
For earth, I went
to the Grand Canyon.
We kind of rented a helicopter,
went inside the Grand Canyon,
stayed there for a week.
And what happened
because of that?
Nothing.
Just my manager got
upset because I was not
available for a week.
So effectively, it was not
heading in any direction.
Then came water.
The water was the big challenge.
Because I wanted
to do scuba diving.
But my friend advised me,
saying that, you know what?
Scuba diving is what
honeymoon couples do.
Think big.
And then I asked him, what
do you mean think big?
Then, he said, there
is a place on Earth
where the Pacific Ocean and
the Atlantic Ocean intersect.
Why don't you take a jump there?
And I was like, that is a dream.
That is fantasy.
That is stupidity.
And then there is
a zone beyond that.
Why do you ever think
I'll get into that zone?
Then, he said, no, Sai.
Let's try out.
And so I started to look
out for people who would go,
who had done that
probably previously.
Then, I met this guy.
He was the first man to walk
the North Pole and South Pole
back in the 1980s.
When I asked him over
email, why did you
walk to North Pole and
South Pole in the 1980s--
that, too-- he said,
just because it's there.
So effectively, then
I realized there
are crazy people on the planet.
Then I asked him,
don't you think
that's a little
stupid thing to do?
Then, he wrote me
an elaborate email.
He said, you know what, Sai?
When I first walked
the South Pole
and then came back
to my native country,
England, the very first
question that people asked me
when I returned from Antarctica
was that, was it cold, Robert?
So effectively, when
he said people--
when you come from
Antarctica, and people ask,
was that continent cold,
then at that moment,
you know that people are
inherently a little stupid.
Therefore, you don't need to
bother about their opinions.
And over email
exchanges, I figured out
that he was going on
another expedition
to Antarctica that
particular year.
So I asked him if I could
join him in the same.
And he more than was glad.
He asked me to fundraise for it.
I went to a couple of companies
and asked them to support me.
And they said, no,
this is not a venture
that they would
be interested in.
So I looked at setting
up my own venture.
I started to train
for the GMAT, wherein
I could raise money
to go ahead and start
going on this expedition.
It was almost like a
six-month planning.
I lived in Argentina
for almost 20 days.
Because the terrain
on the Andes is
going to be similar to
the terrain in Antarctica.
So effectively, I was
training on the Andes.
And if you actually
look at this pic,
well, we trained for 15
days on this Andes range
and then started
on our expedition.
We took all these
lovely pictures.
Then, we went onto
the expedition.
One of the classic mistakes
that I did during training
was that I was never
wearing hand gloves while I
was holding my crutches.
But when I went
to the Antarctic,
the first thing I had to
do was wear hand gloves.
And then I realized the moment
I wear those thick hand gloves,
I can never hold my crutches.
I can never actually
hold my crutches.
So the entire plan
literally went to dogs.
At that moment, I decided I'd
take revenge on the British
because we carried them on our
country for almost 200 years.
So I asked this
British man, can you
carry me for about
two miles so that we
can get into the continent
once we reach that?
He said, OK, [INAUDIBLE].
Then, we designed sledges.
We got pulled for
almost like five miles.
And on Shivaratri day,
at the intersection
of the Pacific and
the Atlantic Ocean,
I decided I'd take what is
called as the polar plunge.
And we recorded that moment.
And finally, on the Shivaratri
day only, we kind of--
I became the first
Asian with a disability
to step onto the
Antarctic continent.
And from there, we kind
of put up these pictures.
And by the time I
returned to India,
this video started to go viral.
And people were like, you
know, a handicapped guy
went to Antarctica.
So this fellow
So then people are like, if
that fellow goes to Antarctica,
he can at least go to
school and all that stuff.
And when people started
to notice all this--
meanwhile, as if all
this was not enough,
old villain re-entered life.
And she was like,
you know, I always
knew that you had the
talent to do excellent life
and that you could do well
and achieve big things.
So why don't you guide my
children also and inspire
them and all that stuff?
And that was the
first point I realized
in life that people's opinions
can change drastically.
They'll have one view of you
today, another view of you
the next day.
Their opinions
have no stability.
And another thing was, as if
all these good things were not
enough, out of nowhere--
remember the video that I first
put up which had two views?
That was picked
up by Aamir Khan.
And he was launching his
show "Satyamev Jayate."
And the amount of research
that went into that video kind
of impressed him.
And he said, why don't
you actually come over
and have a talk on this show?
So this was like a
classic Steve Jobs
quote, where the dots
got connected backwards.
And effectively from
there on, once I
got into "Satyamev Jayate,"
ISB was also interested.
I started working with ISB
and graduated from the school.
I started to work for
home ministry, wherein
we kind of looked at
generating jobs for people
with disabilities where
disability could actually
be an advantage.
But before we get there,
it was at this moment
wherein I started to do the
sky, earth, water thing,
I started to realize that a
lot of people in our country
are very, very stigmatic
about even expressing
that they have a disability.
We are in a city.
We are in Hyderabad.
So effectively, we talk
of words like inclusivity,
accessibility, and all that.
But when you go 50 miles south
of the city, or any direction
of the city, if you
go into a rural area,
people wouldn't even want to
share that their child would
have a disability.
That's primarily because
they're worried about how
the life will actually turn up.
But just reflect that--
reflecting on that
and wondering,
how can I actually
help those people?
I was talking to my
professor at ISB.
And he was like, you
did all these projects
about sky, earth, water, and
all that stuff, which is great.
But it is only working on
the awareness component.
He said, every
social problem has
got three components in all.
One, the awareness component.
Another is the action component.
And third is the
accountability component.
Things like this
generate awareness
that there is a
problem out there.
There could be a
solution out there.
There's a very interesting talk
by my professor-- conversation
with my professor--
where he told me
that, Sai, while a lot of people
say that these activities are
inspiring, ask yourself
what inspiration is.
Inspiration is not about
overcoming a challenge.
Because if you are inspiring
by doing all these activities
and overcoming the
challenge, you're
also sending a soft message that
there is going to be a problem.
And still, people
have to overcome it.
It's almost like a mother
will come to the college.
And if the mother sees
me, she tells that child,
you know what?
There is this kid.
He climbed the three floors.
He kind of did well in life.
So you also climb three floors.
You will also do well
in life and all that.
He told me that
inspiration is not
about overcoming the challenge.
True inspiration is about asking
why the challenge is there
in the first place.
And how can we remove that
challenge once and for all?
He challenged me to
think beyond the obvious.
And he said, you know, stop
on the awareness aspect
and think more on the action
and accountability angle.
And it is there that the
major challenge came.
Because when I started to
work on the action items,
I wanted to generate jobs
for people with disabilities.
Within that, we looked
at four segments.
One segment was the educated
and employed segment,
which is what is a
justice or a fair system--
educated people with
disabilities, those
people being employed.
Then, there are uneducated
people with disabilities.
They are employed.
That's rare.
You wouldn't find
anyone up there.
Then, there are educated
people with disabilities,
but they are not employed.
This is the
discrimination segment.
Finally came the
uneducated people
with disabilities and
not being employed.
There are God knows
how many people exactly
with disabilities
in our country.
Believe it or not, in 2010,
the government of India
even refused to count the number
of people with disabilities.
Because the major challenge--
when we filed the RTA,
we came to know as to why
people with disabilities
were not counted was when
the census is conducted,
you have to go to
a particular place
and ask questions to the people.
And in remote villages,
interior villages and all,
you speak in local language.
So effectively, when
the census is conducted,
and you go to a
particular house,
you have to ask
that person, do you
have anyone with a mental
disability or mental challenge
at your house?
Effectively, in Hindi,
you have to basically ask
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So effectively, that
gets very offensive.
So you just can't go
into a house and say,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So effectively, since there
was no terminology for people
with mental disabilities,
the government
decided a sweet shortcut.
They decided, let's not count.
So effectively, it took a
long time for the government
to decide, we have to frame a
word for this, then ask them.
Right now, their trending
word is [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
So basically, we have our
divine organ right now.
Because of which I can--
I don't know-- do what?
But the government has
decided that right now,
we all will be called
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
And now, we are
going to get counted.
And policies are
going to be framed.
Fair enough.
But there was this huge
group of people who
were uneducated and unemployed.
This is almost like 3%
to 7% of the country.
And they are going
to be left out
of the employment frame, which
means they can't contribute
to GDP, which
means they're going
to be a burden on the
family that's earning,
which means that there is
going to be unrest, which
means that there is
going to be frustration.
And effectively, it was
my goal that instead
of working in the
discrimination segment,
we might want to
work in the segment
where people are
uneducated and unemployed.
That took my focus to
the hospitality industry,
wherein I looked at jobs
for people with disabilities
where disability
could be an advantage.
The primary source of the idea
came from the Mughal emperors,
wherein all the servants of
the queen of the Mughal emperor
either used to be blind,
all the spies or any others
used to be deaf.
They used their
disability in such a way
that effectively in
that job, disability
would be a primary advantage.
Now, I'm not debating the
morals or ethics of this.
But it got the job done.
We looked at certain jobs
where noise could be a problem.
For instance, if there
is a traffic police,
and he's going to get
affected by the traffic noise,
we believe-- and he has to
speak only through signs.
Then, a person with
a hearing disability
would be an ideal fit.
In fact, a person with
hearing disability
could be a job requirement
in that scenario.
Because if you're constantly
exposed to so much noise,
you get frustrated.
Then you get angry.
You get drunk.
Then, you go and beat your wife.
So effectively, you could
prevent this whole chain
of events, wherein
we looked at any job
where noise was going to be
a deterrent to the quality
of the performance,
the hearing impairment
will actually act
as a deterrent.
And we kind of made
a fantastic report
for the hospitality industry.
We also looked at the
pharmaceutical industry.
We looked at a few jobs
in the IT industry.
And we flipped the
paradigm, wherein
instead of asking
corporates to generate jobs
for people with disabilities,
we kind of looked at the people
with disabilities and thought,
hey, what jobs are they
going to be in in which
their disability in itself
is going to be
actually an advantage?
We made a fantastic report.
We submitted it to
the Home Ministry.
I don't know what happened
after that, how many jobs we got
generated, or how
many samosas got
eaten on that research report.
But effectively, we started
to make slow progress.
That took my attention finally
to the third component, which
is on the accountability angle.
A lot of times, people
believe that any issue related
to disability should actually
be addressed by government.
But when I actually
look at it, it
is not something that the
government needs to address.
For instance, if
I go to my father
and say, Dad, this room
and this table's location
here is kind of
hurting me, he does not
tell me, go and speak to
the district collector.
He will come and change.
My dad doesn't run an
initiative at house saying,
today, we'll consider
it as World Disability
Day in our house.
And he doesn't run
inclusivity initiatives.
He doesn't basically
run it like a corporate.
The reason he took care
of me was that he could--
he believed that I was
part of the family.
I wouldn't even call it love.
He believed that it
was his responsibility.
Once I became his
family member, he
believed that
everything I face is
going to be ending up
as the responsibility
or accountability on him.
He took responsibility
for my education.
He took accountability.
When the principals called year
after year, year after year,
and said, your son would not
be an ideal fit at this school,
he moved me around
at multiple schools.
He spoke and convinced
multiple principals.
When my mom kind of took me
across the street every day
all those two years,
they didn't look at it
as an initiative or an
extracurricular activity
at house.
They knew that this was a
fundamental responsibility.
Because they knew that I
was part of the family.
Somehow, when I move into
a corporate environment
from a family, that angle
on, this member is my family,
gets missing.
Because we start to think,
hey, he's different.
My life is different.
I have my own problems in life.
Let me sort that out.
The HR is there for this.
And I believe that is what
we are trying to address
through initiatives like this.
Because you would really want
to understand that each person
right from the bottom of the
ground to the top-level CEO
can play a huge role,
can play a huge role.
It could be something as small
as the height of this chair.
When you are addressing
a particular gathering,
that makes all the
difference to what
the person is going to feel
and excel at the office on.
And when you start to
show so much empathy,
then the person also feels
responsible to contribute.
For instance, remember
back in 10th class,
I really didn't care what
my performance in education
is going to be?
But when I realized that
my parents were putting
in so much effort, and
that they were disappointed
with my performance, and
then I went out of the way
to actually help
and focus and study
and finally start to deliver.
And there came a point
over a period of time
where my own attitude,
abilities, and talents
transformed.
And I sat in front of my dad,
the man who first told me
education is the way out--
there came a day where
I told him, Dad, I need
to go ahead and study abroad.
I don't care what
your fears are.
This is what I need to do.
That's the transformation
that happens.
Through this
transformation, there
are going to be conflicts.
There are going to be villains.
There are going to be opinions.
There are going to be failures.
There are going to be
stupid moments that are
going to be moments of guilt.
But you will realize
that when you're
fighting for what
you are believing in
and when you're
fighting for what
you think is right for your
life, things might go wrong.
But even if they go wrong,
you will do course correction
over a period of time.
And you will end up in a place
wherein hopefully, one day,
you can sit in a place--
sit on a chair like
me, I am doing today,
and probably talk of what
happened over 30 years of life
in a 30-minute seminar.
That's pretty much
what I actually wanted
to convey over this session.
If you have any questions, I'd
be more than glad to take it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]